I'm an idiot,
I work for the Google Play app and development team.
We have been pursuing an endeavor to create applications for children and the family.
How many attendees work for children and family software developers?
Excellent.
If the vision is hidden from one of you, just tell me.
Well, I always like to start with the offer - maybe
Some have already seen this but explained that this
It's about creating great apps for kids and family,
And that's what we're trying to do.
To play the video please.
[Play Video]
[Music playing]
-1, 2, 3.
[Dog bark]
[Child laugh]
- Get -
Now, do we need butter?
-No.
The other way.
this way.
Wonderful.
To do this, bend it like this.
My God!
What we cover.
- I want to cut your hair.
Where is the black color?
Uh, it's in my eyes.
Does this look like my hair?
-Yeah.
3.
correct answer.
-I did it.
your turn.
-okay then.
-That's it.
So everything is fine and clean.
"Why do you sit there like this?"
[Music playing]
[End of Play]
Shadidya Sekomi: I watched this video many times,
Every time I feel chills.
But what we do here is your help to create
More of these family moments,
Google has invested heavily
In the field of children and the family.
How many attendees heard about Google Play
For families?
Which we announced at Google I / O. Okay.
Only a limited number of attendees heard of it.
Sorry, let me try to move to the next slide.
It's basically a new exploration experience on Play.
This is done through a separate section for children and family content
You can subscribe to this section as well
To be in the Play Store.
This allows parents to
Go to a specific place to search
About content for children, either through browsing
Groups for children, by age group, or even by
Famous characters.
Well, I'll talk a little about some key elements
Which we have undertaken in this context.
So the search results are also relevant here.
For example, if you're looking for music,
In the Families section, you see,
The results will be very different,
Because we realize you're looking
For content for children and family.
You'll only see results from apps
Games enabled in the Family Program,
While doing the same search elsewhere on Play
Very different results appear.
And to mention this relevant research, regardless of
Your site, if you're researching - and you know,
Google is really searching.
So if we realize you're looking for children's content,
Children's educational games or apps will appear
For children of three years of age, or in this case,
Coloring for children - thus the results you get will be enhanced,
Or apps and games created for kids--
Because we realized it was a child's search - so the search is enhanced
To appear within the top results,
Regardless of where you are searching.
Again, the research, which is the main means of parents
To search for content for their children
In addition to browsing or characters,
We have made a great effort
To ensure that they have the content you publish and that is appropriate for them.
Earlier figures have mentioned,
We know the importance of characters in children,
Each of them has his favorite character.
They want to get all the interesting content.
I have two children, one at seven and the other at eight
They have gone through various stages of obsession with these characters.
But what we did was that we wanted a specific place - from
Parents view, provides all this content
What is required regarding the character of Pippa pig,
Or Dora, Elmo, Snow Queen, or whatever you want.
So you get apps and games as well
Movies and TV content and books.
Thus, it is a way for parents to find this content.
Then it's for developers like you
Those who invest in licensing, it really is
Gives you an opportunity to show licensed content
In front of users in other ways
Do not just search for it.
Finally, we've added a lot of tools and controls
To facilitate parents find great content and safe
For their children.
For example, we have content evaluation
Which we launched earlier this year.
Everyone in the store - not only children and family,
But everyone is available for them to evaluate the content.
You will not reach the family section
Unless you get an E or E10 rating.
We also let parents know which apps or games they have
Ads or buy in-app if this is important to them.
If you are a parent looking for something
In a certain category, or you want
Knowing its suitability to age, we
We put badges to help you get there.
Finally, we also put more
Controls using password to limit
In-app purchases by children inadvertently.
This was in terms of design and development.
We also invest a lot in marketing
And promotion.
Where we really seek to join more users to
Family section to show them the content you publish.
Of course, there are many types
Email marketing campaigns and social networks.
We work with the bosses who
They have the experience of compiling distinct selections on Play
Offering a lot of seasonal themes.
In addition, we have done something new
Of its kind by establishing an actual event in New York on digital content
A few months ago using content posted by some partners
Important, as the picture shows
Children really enjoyed working with physical and digital content,
Similar to what you saw in the video.
Thus, we talked about design and development side,
But from our point of view, the action
With so many people in attendance,
It is the same store,
Gave us some understanding of how to create a great application,
How to market it, and make money from it.
I wanted to share this with you, including experiences
Some developers.
Some of this seems clear,
Thank you.
To understand your audience,
In the area of ​​children, this may be a little difficult
Because you have two types of audience.
There is a parent who
Will buy the content.
And you have a child who will be the consumer.
And already want to satisfy each other,
Parents are looking for educational value,
They care about something that motivates
The creativity of their children allows them to explore.
Children are looking for exciting and boring things
Are different from those in educational content.
Children want to interact.
You need to take this simple difference into consideration.
And another thing I say to software developers,
Do not try to give everything to everyone
Because this is not really possible.
We know that middle school students are different from young children,
There is even a difference between children
At the age of five and others at the age of eight or
Children at the age of eight and others at the age of 11.
So at Google, our research -
He must think about the main audience that is seeking him
Improve the application to the public
In terms of levels of development and language ability,
And their motor skills, and actually achieve it.
That is why we have age groups,
As you can see, in the family section,
You can enable your app in up to two adjacent age groups.
Also, involve children in your research from the beginning,
So from the moment you think about creating the application, so to speak.
Budge Studios is one of the partners we work with
Hundreds of children have been involved from the start
During the test.
The company tests the game and conducts search groups and questionnaires online.
When thinking about applications,
Do not forget to pay attention to the goal of it, and that in the end
Will attract public attention.
This is also particularly useful
Because these children have parents who
Interact with the content at an early stage
They were with you from the beginning,
They will be the strongest supporters and customers
They influence the field when they tell other children
And parents about the content you publish.
Children are particularly interested in the picture,
You really want to capture their imagination,
Grab their attention.
This is done in part by large and colorful icons
Illustrations, characters, screen shots, and videos
High quality.
In an informal questionnaire we had with children,
We asked what the main thing you were looking for
When you choose the application?
I thought there might be a lot of different things
When I thought of myself as an adult, the answer was one
It is the symbol.
Children choose the application based on code.
How many people are surprised?
Maybe I was the only one.
Because I was thinking, in the purpose of the application
And how important it is
I thought of it as a mother of children.
But in any case, you should not neglect to think about
What suits children.
It is also necessary to think about the vocabulary of children in particular,
And the size of their fingers, so small words are chosen
Large lines, and lots of colors.
Smart Study says one of our partners in Japan
They do not use any text,
They rely only on images in their lists,
It also has buttons large enough
Keep children who can not read or their motor skills
Very low are able to participate and interact.
So you need to turn education into fun, otherwise it will not work.
Also remember that the parent is in need of
To be convinced that this thing
The purchase is worth the child's benefit.
So it needs to be in an educational way and in an attractive way.
Also the company [? IntelligeOA?] Is one of the most application developers
A success on the Play platform for children's content,
This company thinks without complacency in what
If the content will add an educational value
or not?
Even if the three-dimensional effect is truly impressive,
But it will detract from the value of learning you get,
They do not add it.
In addition to this, you need
Also make the application simple.
Things like simplicity and clarity are of great importance.
So when Avokiddo started designing Thinkrolls 1 and 2
They told us that they excluded all the complex scenarios,
Complex user interface, multi-screen levels,
They only kept the application simple.
Until children interact with the application, this should happen naturally.
Children and parents can not be affected
On the directory try to find out
How does this thing work?
They will leave the app before they understand it.
Then stress again, as you may have heard at a previous session
Today, place your focus on quality.
Quality is really important,
It's important because people pay for it.
You can see the jump in revenue by adding
One Star.
But in the area of ​​children, it is very different.
Because when you buy for someone else,
Like a parent who buys a child,
You want a signal telling you, you know,
That this will impress your child.
So they use ratings as one of these signals
For admiration and leave a high rating.
I think there is a great possibility that my child will love him.
It must therefore be reaffirmed
That the application users in the initial trial version
Who loved the application
Or the game will go to the store and leave an assessment.
So we talked about how to design a great application.
We will now talk about how to make profits from it?
I think you are familiar with monetization
In the field of children and family has its difficulty,
These are some of the models we have seen in
Children's apps, subscriptions and ads
In-app purchases and surcharges.
I'll talk about her,
Each has its advantages and disadvantages.
I think you should find what fits
The content you provide is the best.
For extra charges, great for extra charges
Every time someone gets something, you will receive money.
When downloading, you pay for it,
Which generates profits in your bank account.
But this works really well if you are a well-known brand,
If you spend money to establish yourself as a brand.
In fact, Toca Boca and Sago Sago are walking
Well in this frame.
Because when you subtract the new,
The user is aware of the quality of the quality he will receive.
The experience of the thing before you buy it will benefit anything in life,
So we have policies to return,
Where you can check the app before getting involved forever.
Why should apps and games be different?
But in the family, this is very important
Because, by going back to the question I posed earlier,
When someone buys something for someone else,
Risk increases.
So you need to provide the signals they want,
I was reading a paper
Show that parents are willing to pay $ 99 in something
They know that their child will love, use and relate to it
For a long time, but they will not
Spending $ 0.99 on something
It will get them bored in 10 minutes.
But how do they know that their child will enjoy it?
So this model works really well
When the parent feels that
This content will appeal to my child.
We come to the annoying part of this, well,
I receive notifications constantly
To spend more and spend more and spend more on this,
Then I need to buy this to move to the next level.
StoryToys has dealt wonderfully to solve
This is where content is made free of charge
At first, but then help you buy one inside the application
Get the rest of the application.
This gives the company the advantage of the child's experience of the application
The parent knows that his child will enjoy
Content but without notice
Parent time after time with many parts of the content
Needed to be purchased.
Subscriptions are also very popular in children.
Well, I really want to do a quick survey
Among the developers of children's programs present, to learn
How many applications have additional charges?
Okay.
How many of you has an in-app purchase?
How many of you have subscriptions?
How many of you have ads?
So subscriptions are becoming more popular.
Of course, the good news is this
Is the low cost of acquisition of the user, which is great,
Then the flow of profits frequently to the developer,
Where he can continue to invest in the product.
But part of the challenge here remains
You need to renew or add something new,
Or find a way to make parents ready to continue
Pay on a frequent basis because they are
They get something.
By the way if you use subscriptions,
For your information, you do not need to
Processing of financial transactions,
Google makes the payment exactly as it is
Pay with paid or in-app purchases.
Although this is not necessarily a business model
In itself, but I want to address the licensing of intellectual property.
How many attendees have intellectual property that others have licensed?
That's part of the reason behind
Provide pages for characters, for this investment.
While it is really wonderful
That you get the target audience,
A type of audience that already exists for the brand.
This gives you an already existing brand marketing
Which helps you to challenge
The discovery of user acquisition.
However, you also have a certain standard or quality level
The application needs to be adhered to,
Where brand lovers expect it,
Or the trademark owner will exercise some degree of control over what
Produced.
It is also clear that the economic side
It will be different,
It is a point to think about
If you enter the licensing area.
Well, we talked about application design,
We now turn to income from it,
How do I attract users to the app?
How does the user understand the need for the application?
Well, one of the most important things to achieve this
Is to create a compelling store data list to view,
They are of particular importance in the area of ​​children,
I was talking about symbols and their actual significance to them.
So make sure they are attractive,
If someone is looking for a developer like you, be careful
To find you actually.
So headlines must be very clear up
Appear and stand out in search results.
In the list of your store data, first describe clearly
Role played.
Then add all the prizes you have earned.
But should be clear in talking about what it offers
The application does not offer.
After getting people's attention,
Put attractive screenshots and videos,
Because this is what drives them to switch to
Page to download
Content and install it.
How many attendees have tried the A / B test with data lists
the shop?
Okay.
It's something we launched at Google I / O,
I think, this includes everyone,
You may have heard this in the previous presentation, as well
People have seen great success using this.
And for those who do not know it, it allows you
Try any part of your listing,
Through A / B tests, you know who works better.
If it is a different symbol or a different title
Or different graphics, etc.
BabyFirst uses this test strongly,
And found when changing the code
It has achieved a 10% increase in the number of installations.
So I changed him immediately.
So I would recommend you use this test with something
In the importance of the symbol in the field of children.
Then there are the developer pages that you have
We launched it at the I / O conference, which is a way for you guys
To establish a brand for yourself on Play.
How many attendees have developer pages?
For those who do not have,
I certainly advise them to look at this,
Where you can place a banner ad and an icon representing
Your brand and unique apps.
It is also important when conducting marketing campaigns,
Especially if it is not specific to a specific application,
You can then direct people to your developer page
Rather than having to select the content pane
Which you want to direct them to.
And then we all hear about things that take effort,
Among them also get the best applications
Games for children.
So, take care to mobilize the audience and attract users
Who know their love for the content you publish
Ask them to leave comments on it.
Especially in the field of children and the family, because for us
We parents have gotten used to
To hear from other parents to see what they like
Then we turn to watch the content, and perhaps the children heard from each other about the game.
So this is a place for parents
Read what other parents do
Use this as a way to find something similar to it
For their child.
Also, take care to respond to comments if users leave comments
Or expressed an admiration for something, or left their opinion,
Do not forget to answer them and keep in touch with them
To create your community.
Now how many of you have a channel on YouTube
For the applications and games it offers?
well good.
This is actually more than I have seen during my speech on this in the United States.
I know there are kids on YouTube.
I think there is an increase of 200% in the family channels
On YouTube alone.
Children communicate with other creators,
They add content from users' creation,
They watch other children playing.
So you must be there.
You need a page to view movies
The promotion of the games you offer, the style of play,
Or you can provide user-generated content,
Provide tips, or identify users
New products.
Now we have another thing which is the cards - well, I say now,
I mean actually a few months ago,
Where this feature has emerged shortly.
But now it has become an evolving form of captions,
You can be inside the video itself
Place a card to guide people anywhere,
Including to your app.
Even if they're watching a video about the app
And they wanted to get it, you just one click literally,
Give them the opportunity to move there and get the app.
Finally, you need to be in where your audience is,
So he was interested in promoting the appropriate channels for the family.
Including parents' codes and groups of mothers,
And other forums where there are influential people
The cemeteries are already important.
They will help you to get the audience
And know who you need to reach.
So do your best to know
Influencers in your particular area
Or influencing for the content you publish in particular
Encourage them to tell the public about your app.
We actually do this in Play in the Family section
Through expert groups drawn from experts such as Levar Burton
And other entities, where they talk about applications
And games they love and help recommend content
I have other users.
How many attendees participate in the "Design for Families"
On Play?
Compared to the number of children's software developers,
This is actually very few.
If you do not participate, and you are in the field of children and family,
I encourage you to get more information
At developer.android.com/families
Within the program.
But then, if you go to the developer console
- All applications -
They moved to the pricing and distribution department,
And select the box "I want
Join Play for Families. "
This in turn leads to placing your affiliate content in
Play for Families, and you'll get all the features
Which I talked about in the past about the research and so on,
And you're also everywhere in the usual Play Store,
Thus double benefit is achieved.
Where you will not be excluded from a place to be in the other.
I do not believe this,
I have already finished early.
I never do this.
[Music playing]